everything you do is at the
service of the brand
what is this class about it is a
marketing class
go on the selling floor
deal with the consumers help them in the
fitting rooms
you have to listen you have to see how
people live
it's all about the power of the image
communication visual merchandising
the packaging the logo
the world is completely product polluted
too much everything in every color every
price
so what would your brand
bring why would it be different than
anyone
[Music]
i was 20 year old in this factory i said
will you please allow me to make some
samples that i will try to sell in
america
with a child in my belly and with two
big suitcases full of little
dresses i sailed
to america that was the beginning
of my business
[Applause]
i had huge successes and huge failures
and the only reason why i was able to
survive
is because i did instinctively
what is now being taught
[Music]
you have to be close to who you are what
you want
how you want it because all through your
career
the closer you put the product to the
consumer
and the more authentic you are the
longer you will last
i am dean von furstenberg and
this is my master class
you